yeah uh well um again just you know for
the purpose of engaging in open I'm
happy to I welcome all questions yeah so
um I noticed that uh one of the first
things you said was that the United
States was an experiment and that it was
the first moral nation and that the DNA
of our country is freedom and so on um
and I also noticed that you didn't
mention that the country was also
founded on you know extermination of the
indigenous population conquest of half
of Mexico and slavery and um you know
and furthermore I think you have to make
a distinction between while I do love
this country absolutely I think you have
to make a distinction between the
internal fre of the country and the
external threat that it poses and these
two things have just been uncorrelated
throughout history so while internally
it's the freest country in the world
externally it poses a tremendous threat
given its overwhelming power and I think
if you look at the record it's
uncontroversial that our relations with
the Middle East have involved extensive
violence and aggression and subversion
and so on so my point is that if you are
interested in protecting the country
from the threat of cot Terror and
Islamic radicalism and so on I am too
but the point is that by uh condemning
them and pointing out their acts of
aggression uh in my mind is is uh sort
of fruitless because there's not very
much you can do about it what you can
have an effect on is what we do and our
relations with the Arab world that can
have a big effect and furthermore we we
can have an impact on that I think if
history shown anything it's that an
aroused public can have an impact on
policy which can then lead to much more
open and peaceful and diplomatic
relations with these you know Outsiders
and so on so isn't that where our energy
should be focused not towards uh
condemning their radicalism and their
violence over which we can have no
effect except escalating violence which
is likely to just engender more violence
in return
nonsense how do you really feel it's
completely nonsense what you
exhibit is a devastating inability to
distinguish between right and wrong and
good and
but there's some bad things
too but but really it's not informing
any of your decisions it's not informing
any of your opinions so what are you
suggesting so you're suggesting that we
abandon freedom and we align with
radical states that promise to
annihilate Freedom loving states in the
Middle East to to what to achieve peace
do you really believe that can you
really deduce that did that two and two
really equal five first of all a I do
not agree with your interpretation I
don't know that I agree with your love
of the country but if you say so I'll
let I'll let you go there how it was
founded and why it was founded it was
founded by Men by the way men and women
and families who risked everything I
mean when I say risk everything these
were men with names with wealth with
with with with families uh not let's say
you know murderers by CH Rivera for
example and I know you wear them on your
T-shirt I so don't get wearing the
murderer on your T-shirt okay but wait
these were men who had everything to
lose everything to lose and they risked
everything and of course their lives for
an idea for an idea and the idea was a
government a moral government based on
individual rights why do I say moral
because everything that the constitution
was designed was based upon the
extension of individual rights and
individual property rights and
capitalism okay that was the premise of
this country that was the prise of this
country now look we can you and I can go
back and forth on slavery and I probably
agree with you that they made the deal
and there was a lot of fighting at the
time it was Southern States and they
wouldn't go along and so a compromise
was made which again just validates my
point that in any compromise between
good and evil evil
profits so a compromise was made and
they were thinking that they would
address it later on just to establish
the union because they weren't the South
wasn't a capitalistic s was slavery I
mean it was it's it was surf up is what
it was but the north
wasn't and then of course it was
reconciled in the worst of ways or in
this case the best of ways it's a civil
war where hundreds of thousands were
killed now are you looking for
Perfection I don't see perfection in
anything I don't expect perfection in
anything but I do look for intent and
then of course subsequently the end
result but intent is very important and
I don't believe America ever acted to
impose uh an oppressive system America
was the only country that would finally
go in yes finally go in World War One
World War II and destroy the enemy
destroy the evil and I believe it was
evil and then leave but not before
building the
country not before I mean looking you
want to see a difference in in in
capitalism versus communism or socialism
look at East Germany and West Germany
West Germany is one of the engines of
the world World East Germany was a
cancer or North Korea and South
Korea North Korea is a 30 million
goua it is a an entire state of of
abject poverty and
starvation but they have but they're
nuclear that's the priority for them so
I just disagree I believe you see and I
know that President Obama thinks much
this way also um he he's um you know
like Plato I believe that peace is a
parenthesis I don't believe it's a
natural state of the world and I believe
that America has been a Force for good I
believe that and so I don't see it the
way you see it going in I you know what
you know I don't know what you what you
want to do you want to just be in
operation fetal position and just wait
for the worst to happen do you not think
the worst could happen I mean you take
history
yes I'm just saying you know appeasement
this idea of appeasement look you know
Hitler could be stopped at
Czechoslovakia but it was this idea that
you know what let's not make waves let's
just you know let's just give him what
he wants until it got to the point of no
return until you couldn't stop him and
do I see that happening I do I see that
happening with Iran I really do and
believe me it will not be there will be
no satisfaction for me to come back to
you in five years and say I told you so
just like when I was writing about Egypt
and getting my ass handed to me in
January of 2011 saying this is a Muslim
Brotherhood this is an Islamic
supremacist movement now the young I'm
not saying they young Freedom lovers out
there they had no idea what they were
dealing with but those of us that cover
this we saw it and it is telling to me
that under the Obama Administration
you're witnessing Revolutions of Islamic
imperialism and expansionism he had
moderate tesia just you know um um
elected a um Islamic supremacist
government want a Sharia you had Libya
now I'm not going to Shell for Gaddafi
it's not going to happen but you have a
transitional government now that has
ties to alqaeda and jihadist elements
and they promis a Shara State and Egypt
I do not believe you should have thrown
Mubarak away with both hands I don't
believe that and under Bush if you spoke
to Egyptians and I I'm of course in a
lot of contact with Egyptian bloggers it
was only after we lost the Congress to
Pelosi in 2006 where those reforms
stopped being made by bar you need to
know these things you can't make
informed decisions if you don't know
wait let me just I just want to finish
this
one thank you and then I'm Happ to the
floor um but it is if you looked at the
elections the number one winner was the
Muslim Brotherhood then of course even
worse the salais under Bush every
Revolution really was a freedom
Revolution the RH Revolution was a real
Freedom Revolution the the cedar
Revolution where they where they wanted
to expel Syria and they did in in
Lebanon that was a real re that was a
real Freedom Revolution look Pamela all
these things can be debated and they can
be debated fairly okay and I endorse
what you said at the beginning about the
need for a fair and honest debate what I
don't understand though is how you swear
that initial claim with your comment to
my student based on a single comment he
made that he doesn't understand the
difference between right and wrong how
can that comment promote fair and honest
dial okay how can you make that
extrapolation and how can you be a
Tribune for fair an honest dialogue when
you're dealing in rhetoric like that I
was not attempting to deal in rhetoric
and if I insulted the student I do
apologize it just showed to me a
complete lack of understanding of right
and wrong and so I had to call
it I had to call it as I See You can
disagree with me but that's how I saw it
and again I will not couch my words to
make everybody feel better I'm not here
to do that and I am sure that you get
plenty on a daily basis from the other
side so I have to give you a shot an
inoculation in a in a half an hour
that's what I'm going to do th go ahead
and call them people yes the young lady
behind the gentleman um well you said
that we defeated the by marginalizing
them when
they well I mean it was law enforcement
but I'm saying in the perception on the
on in the landscape the psychological
landscape of America they became an
abhorent idea just like if I say the
name now what comes into your mind
you're like you know they became an aor
they were not always an aor idea no I I
know I understand um and I'm just saying
I'm asking if we were to marginalize
like the jihadists in America or the
Muslims in America that you know we do
not want to marginalize the Muslims in
that would be terrible that' be making
everybody pay it's like you know
everybody pays because one person no no
no no no but you have to identify what
the threat is what's motivating and
what's the inspiration or ideology
that's that's motivating okay I'm just
confused what your end goal is like what
do you what's your end goal for like you
know like Muslim relations in America
just confed again with that Muslim
religions in I feel bad when I hear that
as if they're separate why do they have
to be separate we're all Americans they
come here to live and and and love and
have families and work why does it have
to be separate why I don't understand
that I I I I just want you to know I can
never go there I will never go there
there is a problem with a very pure
Islam authentic pure you know third
chapter you know offensive Jihad there's
a problem with that I don't believe I
believe most Muslims are secular I don't
believe that most Muslims want to commit
Jihad I I just don't and that's my
premise that most people are
good so just so that you know did I did
you finish your question or did I keep
interrupting oh no I'm done okay yes sir
so um you the terminology that You' used
is to call it the ground zero mosque but
since since part 511 isn't a mosque it's
a community center it has a culinary
school food court swi and pool
basketball court movie theater and it's
not on Ground Zero it's near it I'm
wondering what is the radius that the uh
Muslim
Community is not allowed to build a
community
center what would you say it's a Bosque
with
amenities I mean it's it's a it's a m
it's a MOS two two top twoo close it's a
MOS with
amenities and the fact that that
building was destroyed in the attacks on
911 makes it Ground Zero do you really
think that Osama Bin Laden when he was
planning the 911 attacks the two planes
should go in that he really thought that
the buildings would fall the way they
fell didn't you think you hoped to take
out lower Manhattan would anybody have
understood that the heat from the planes
would have melted those columns there
was no way of knowing that I mean he was
sharp he wasn't that sharp and so uh
clearly I they can build it anywhere
else they can put that Islamic that
building was destroyed in the 9/11
attacks it should have been declared a
woman moral it should have been a
landmark it should be a shrine to the
over 270 million victims of over
Millennium of Jihadi Wars land
Appropriations cultural annihilations
and enslavements not that building that
was really just so that you know it is
Ground Zero and it is a mosque then they
said it's not a mosque it's a press bace
a press bace is a mosque they play it's
a game then on you know it was Cordova
Cordova Cordova then when it was exposed
on television by myself and others what
Cordova means on Monday it was kova and
on Tuesday it was Park 51 and nobody
questioned it in the media the media
wanted that mask they did um I have no
problem with masks that mask was uh you
know was deeply um offensive and and and
humiliating so that's my answer to your
question yes first of all thank you for
being here uh my question actually ties
into the previous one it's just about
your work um I see that you were
involved as a producer in a movie a
documentary called Ground mosque second
wave of 911 taex I'm was curious to hear
your thoughts on that and how the
phrasing of that title you know how did
you what was the process by which you
came about that would you rephrase that
title you have the opportunity would you
you know I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on that it's a very good
question actually I've never been asked
that before um ground M yes because
that's what it is second wave of the 911
attacks how that came to me was at one
of the landmark hearings early in the
fight one of the 911 family members
rosalene Talon who lost her only brother
a beloved brother got up to speak to the
to the to the committee and as she was
speaking
there were agitators in the audience
that started to scream at her
racist bigot and I thought oh my God
look at this woman she lost her only
sibling brother that she loved and
adored and she actually gave me a CD
with him you know on playing in the
pipes um and she stands up for what she
believes in at a hearing which by the
way we lost lost them all because the
politicians wanted it wanted it and
President Obama wanted it and she's
being attacked again and every single
911 family member that opposed it was
being attacked again and then when the
CNN poll came out saying that 70% of the
Americans were against
it 70% of Americans were racist
islamophobic
ands and this was an attack this was
another attack a stealth Jihadi attack
in the information war in this battle
space and that's how I saw it and that's
that's what the movie is about the movie
is and I have a copy I'll leave with you
I know how youd probably love to show it
to your class next year
um sure a GI um but but I wanted people
to understand how it happened you've
been hearing one thing and one thing
only from the media I mean you had NBC
News named Sharie Al
Gamal the person of the year the NBC
person here here is a man who defaulted
on not one $100,000 loan but two
$200,000 did not pay his rent so whole
property was evicted um had the audacity
to say it's not Ground Zero it's not
Ground Zero it's not Ground Zero and yet
applied for $5 million from the ground
zero rebuilding fund the 911 fund I mean
and he had a rap sheet you know there's
a I'm not going to get into the he
really not he wasn't an architect that
would be muhamad Khan yeah no yeah no
but the developer Sharie Alamar and he's
NBC Man of the Year why solely because
he OS this it was it was outrageous so
everything the media said was demonizing
there was no presentation of objective
reporting and this is what I think is
sorely Laing from the landscape
absolutely and completely is objective
reporting just the facts of which there
really was none so I think that your
your your um uh much information is uh
skewed and it's it's it's biased not by
your own fault but it should tell you